we've got four scenarios right over here
in each scenario we have a
we have a hydroxide anion and then we
have another molecule and right over
here this molecule this is a bromo
methane so it's a bromo group attached
to a carbon and this carbon isn't
attached to any other carbons it's only
attached to other hydrogens so carbon
like this we call a prime we call
actually not a primary we call this a
methyl carbon
we call this
a methyl
carbon because it is attached to no
other carbons
now let's think about this right over
here what's the difference between this
scenario and that one we still have our
hydroxide anion we solve the bromo group
but now this carbon is attached to
another carbon so this right over here
is a primary carbon so that is a primary
primary
carbon
it's attached to one other carbon and i
think you see a pattern here what about
this one well this carbon right over
here is a secondary carbon it's attached
to two other carbons
secondary
carbon
and then finally this carbon right over
here is a tertiary carbon it's attached
to three other carbons
tertiary
carbon
and as we'll see in a few seconds the
fact that it has these other carbons and
these other carbons kind of might block
some of the
blocks some or all of the reaction it
will change what actually what actually
goes on
so let's go first to this first scenario
right over here we have a hydroxide
anion we've already seen that that a
hydroxide anion is a decent nucleophile
so this right over here is a nucleophile
nucleophile
and bromine is a decent leaving group
it's a decent leaving group
leaving group
and so assuming that it's in a
appropriate solution we'll cover that in
future videos you could imagine
you could imagine that
that one of these that this if this
hydroxide kind of bumps into this
bromomethane in just the right way
that these this pair right over here
could form a bond could form a bond with
this carbon and just as that is
happening essentially the carbon is
gaining half of a bond which is a kind
of equivalent of a electron charge so
then this bromine could take away both
this entire pair
this entire pair instead of just kind of
sharing it and having the equivalent of
one electron charge from this pair it
has both of them and then it'll become
the bromide anion we've already seen
that before that is an sn2 reaction sn2
nucleophilic substitution where both
reactants both reactants the nucleophile
and the leaving group are involved in
the rate determining step and this will
actually be
quite fast
so quite
quite fast right over here
now let's look over here the only
difference we already said is the
existence of this ch3 now even though
we've drawn it written it down ch3 when
it's written down doesn't look a lot
bigger than an h remember ch3 i mean
this is almost as this is roughly the
size of this thing right over here so
this if we were to actually draw it out
with a hydrogen bonds this is quite this
is quite large this is quite large right
over here and remember in in chemistry
and organic chemistry we always draw
these neat and clean reactions but
that's not the way it happens in real
life these things are all bumping in a
solution and bumping from every
direction and depending on how they bump
and the relative energies the bonds the
reactions may or may not happen and so
in this scenario in this scenario this
fairly big part of this molecule might
block it might block the approach it
might block the approach of a hydroxide
anion coming from that direction the
good thing is well i guess if you view
sn2 reactions as good is that there's
still other directions that it can come
in from so you could still see the sn2
reaction you could still see the sn2
reaction
could still see it but it's going to be
a bit slower it's going to be a bit
slower so we maybe here we could write
we could write a bit slower but still
fast
a bit
slower
but still fast
but still
now let's think about this scenario and
once again i think you see where it's
going the only difference now is the
secondary carbon we have these two
groups here remember these are these are
much larger than the way that i've drawn
it you have a carbon attached to three
hydrogens so now we're blocking from two
directions so once again you can still
have your sn2 reaction
you can still have your sn2 reaction but
it's going to happen a lot slower it's
going to happen a lot slower so now
you're going to have a slow you're going
to have slow sn2 reaction
and now finally what's happening here
well here this entire side is blocked we
have a ch3 ch3 ch3 this hydroxide anion
isn't going to be able to get through it
is being hindered so here
we have no
no sn2 now you might be saying wait why
did it come from the other end well
remember sn2 reactions right when the
nucleophile
the nucleophile is attacking from one
side and the leaving group is leaving
from the other if the nucleophile were
coming in from here the leaving group
would have trouble leaving from there it
wouldn't work out as well sn2
nucleophile from one side leaving group
from the other now the only thing that
that could reasonably happen here and it
is reasonable and actually we've even
seen it when we looked at sn1 reactions
is maybe the leaving group leaves first
and this is actually the tertiary carbon
is bad for the sn2 but it's good for
stabilizing a for for for having a
stable carbo cation if this bromine
group
if this bromine takes that pair and
becomes bromide then this becomes a
carbocation which will be reasonably
stable because that positive charge can
kind of be spread amongst its brothers
and then at that point it's not crazy
for a nucleophile and you could even
have a nuclear weaker nucleophile than
the hydroxide anion to come in and
actually form a bond now this general
idea that we're talking about in this
video this this idea that a reaction
happening or not happening because of of
in three dimensions of something
hindering the reaction this is called
steric hindrance
steric
hindrance steric refers to is happening
in three dimensions the size and shape
of molecules hindrance is that that
three-dimensional size and shape is
hindering the reaction so the steric
hindrance is greatest right over here
and it's the least right over here for
the sn2 reaction